so weapons is very important if
someone has a weapon and attacked me for
having my money
i give him my money even if i'm just
saying and i'm a ufc champion
however someone put a knife on my throat
here
and
he's telling me to go in the trunk
now
i don't want to go in a trunk because i
know it might i've seen this movie and
it's a bad ending so things that i can
do first is always make sure that i try
to make my hand as close as possible as
the weapon and i try to be as close
range as possible i can act like
i want to to scare you yeah please
please
boom see here i use my body and then i
can go
and break you know so the idea is to use
your entire body to deflect the weapon
so if the weapon is like this and the
blade is coming out this way i use the
element of surprise you see i use my
body not only grabbing him like this so
if he try to come back with the the
knife it's solid then i can go and break
if he if it's the blade this pointing
the other side is something
here
here in
here i can i can i can use
my body always to smother the weapon
you